he's Roger Bennett men in Blazers
co-host pick up a copy of Encyclopedia
Blazer Tanika and check out the twelve
part podcast series American Fiasco
which looks at the Apocalypse Now early
days of American soccer between 1994
1998 World Cups Roger good morning how
are you
I'm Patrick I'm sick with nerves never
for a game never for a mere sports event
have I just been so apprehensive filled
with dread haven't slept in three days
I'm just warning you but the notion of
an England that wins the notion of an
England that wins it's almost
incomprehensible to me okay but when we
talked about this at the beginning of
the World Cup and what was that noise
they're a bunch of books just fell down
behind your desk oh they did I thought
that was England falling apart right in
front of us Roger but but it feels like
you know if England could find a way for
a painful accident they always did so
what's different about this year well
the only logical rational scientific
explanation can be the I became an
American that's all it took just needed
me to depart from the country to test a
scale in the other way to make in
England was glorious for 28 years this
English football team has suffered
self-sabotage gone through a cycle a
routine cycle of humiliation where these
players our heroes would would strap on
kind of like bowler hats or English
Tommy
tin hats beyond the back of the pages
before they leave for the World Cup with
a bulldog and their arm and an English
flag on the back saying we're gonna do
it lads we're gonna bring it home and
then they would just proceed to crap out
in the most humiliating way where the
English jersey just felt like chainmail
for them this team is young and scarred
psychologically they did something
fascinating before they left they said
you know what we're not gonna win it
we're gonna go and we're gonna have some
fun one of them said that we're gonna go
and enjoy themselves and at the time
everyone held at the prospect of English
football players actually enjoying
themselves it and
ethical that we we hate success leave
Coogan once said if you give them
Englishmen the choice between his own
success or your failure he'll choose
your familiar every time he loves
failure and these young guys it's a
lesson about life damn these young guys
with limited goals they never said they
were going to win they said they were
going to go and enjoy themselves and
freed from the pressure of their own
self expectation they've really thrived
in Russia and it's been a joy to watch
most popular Harry in England right now
is you know this - that can take the
risk and neither am i married to a woman
who speaks in an English accent called
Megan does Harry Cade our captain a an
Englishman who is so clinical in front
of goal he's probably the most German
mind trapped in an English body just
absolutely ruthless clinical he looks
like he's just jumped out of a soft with
camel after fighting the Red Baron over
the English skies and one I mean just a
English archetype he's a young captain
he's a wonder a human wonder and the
other gentleman the revelation of the
tournament from from an English
perspective is our defender Harry
Maguire this thunderous he'd probably be
a linebacker if he was born in Alabama
or in this great country he's an
enormous unit he's got and a forehead
that it is big and as wide as three
English counties there's another English
player who told it revealed his nickname
they call him slab head head he just
it's like tombstone of a head and he
gets that head on any set piece and that
ball he he can head the ball further and
harder than I can kick it so it's
McGwire or cane it doesn't matter no no
I'm a Prince Harry Prince Harry vs Harry
Kane yeah it's Harry Maguire or Harry
Kane no one cares about Prince Harry's
yesterday's news we're all about
football and in nine months time there
will be hundreds of accidental babies in
England and all of them whether they're
a boy or a girl will be called Harry
Harry chain even even girls are going to
be called Harry I like that yeah Harry
good yeah it'd be a no be really
period period Cain the leatherby Harry
or Jordan or Gareth you can take your
pick boys or girls okay I
speaking of Prince Harry Megan Markel is
sporting an English accent now I know I
want you to tell me how long is what's
the allowable time for an American to an
establish an English accent where the
locals are going to accept that she's an
actress she's an actress she's been
training for this role all the life I
imagined I believe I believe certainly
is if you are musically trained then you
naturally adapt incredibly quickly so
that my cousin Richard Bennett a lesson
Owen Bennett he moved to America at the
same time as I did and immediately
became him really it just he started the
tour like Michael Jackson things oh hey
guys how you doing I have never had any
kind of an American accent because I
have no musical ear he was cursed by
having a musical ear he went
mid-atlantic so English people hated him
immediately because they thought he was
American and Americans hated him because
they thought he was an Englishman he was
trying to pretend to be American Megan
may well have a musical ear in which
case she's probably not aware that she's
walking around sounding like Dick Van
Dyke just be like Oh Harry the muscles
let's go up the elephant around the
castle God lover I bet she's got a
musical ear and it just happened she's
in Italy in the period of time that's
known as a Madonna and believe it as a
jumble that her and Madonna have become
whirring within the English I think when
it's Paltrow 2 as well
all the great yeah he's a Roger Bennett
co-host of men in Blazers and pick up
encyclopedia blazer Tanika and check out
the 12 part podcast series American
Fiasco we were just talking about the
United States there was a column written
yesterday that talked about why can't
the United States be like Croatia like
why can't we be as successful and have a
team in the semis so if you were going
to
I'm gonna make you president of USA
soccer so what's the link here without
official career now now we can this just
into the Dan Patrick show newsroom Roger
Bennett who is now an American is now
the president of USA soccer all right
now so the one thing that has to happen
for the United States to be able to
compete with the likes of Croatia is
what you know the Croatia are a
fascinating they've got these two
midfielders Maude's rich and racket it's
you remind me of that the great UMass
guards Treviso and Padilla just two guys
with kind of world-class understanding
that happened to hail from a footballing
culture which is deeply deeply ingrained
I'm deeply bullish about the American
future I have to say the one thing I
would day way if you look at what
England have done England who lost to
Iceland just two years ago in a major
tournament and were humiliated and we're
about as low as you can go in the
doldrums as we are here in the United
States and what England did they they
slayed all the kind of old culture of
Heroes that all of the the guys who have
a mentality of a failure they got rid of
all of them and they went into this
tournament playing the babies these guys
were too young to know they had to be
afraid and so in the same way the United
States has this incredible crop of young
talent I mean you obviously know
Christian política de sha and some st.
Louis who's just moved to Werder Bremen
thing he's just turned 18 a ginger
prince who just so calmly reminds me I
met him in st. Louis a couple of weeks
ago he reminds me of the young English
players you know he said whatever level
he plays out he feel he's going to score
a goal it doesn't matter he's just
bursting with confidence we have Tim
Waya
who Brooklyn born the son of the library
Liberian president wants want Footballer
of the year of the of the year George
where we have this whole crop of young
talents and to some degree finding the
right next leader funny enough
if I was US Soccer president the thing
I'd obsess about who is going to be the
manager of the US team going forward
it's going to be the key question you
look at what England have done with this
young manager who believes in youth
Gareth Southgate a gentleman who wears a
waistcoat is so optimistic incredibly
humble and let's kept the mood around
this players light warm optimistic made
them connect to the fans again made them
use social media in a way which has made
them incredibly endearing and lovable
the most important thing that can happen
for u.s. soccer is to choose the right
manager someone who is tactically at
that with an understanding of
world-class football which is very rare
in America our coaching is incredibly
insular within a bubble an incredibly
low level and then play these young guys
we need to slay off that older
generation that old hierarchy that kind
of anyone over the age of 30 that would
be my law will not be playing for the
u.s. again let's stop playing the babies
damn Patrick all right by the way in the
last 10 minutes you've gone we for
England and we for the United States so
I mean I'm gonna allow it this time
around but you know all of a sudden
England's doing well and then you attach
the we you came over here we came a US
citizen and now don't we you know what I
think in every we come when the US play
America I cheer for the US every with
every atom of my energy the English
thing is nostalgia for me it's muscle
memory it's I realized this world cup
I've spent hours of my life watching the
England team I have spent minutes of
those of hours and hours hours minutes
having happy memories all they've done
is give me incredible misery and it has
been fascinating there's a song that's
very popular from that's been taken on
by England if you look on the internet
so many memes about it cause footballs
coming home which was an English chant
from the 9090 the song it was done by
two comedians in the 1990s a song a
tribute to the pain the failure just a
misery of being an English football fan
and it's been taken on even Prince
William is leaning into the camera
saying football's coming home even Drake
did it today at Wimbledon and it's a
song that started as a joke and now no
one knows how to deal with the fact that
it could actually happening
just 90 minutes away 90 minutes today
away against Croatia please don't let it
go to extra time for the love of God if
it goes to penalties kill me damn
Patrick in England could win at the time
when the nation of England is for
Britain is falling apart with the brexit
and the government front pages of the
British newspapers England's falling
apart Britain falling apart the back
pages the sports pages England coming
together so it's a nice thing for the
circus it's our last hope and Godspeed
to the boys today but would you rather
and I don't understand your agony or
your pain but if you knew England was
going to lose the finals to France so
would you rather they got to the finals
in lost or lose today by the way whoever
wins this game Croatia or England today
France will crush either 1990 your
friend to your 2018 whoa wait wait were
we gone over the last 10 minutes talk we
were hyping up England and all of a
sudden there it's gonna come to a
crashing halt here ultimately ultimately
you know and all of all of the guys in
your studio know that Sports is about
memories and the World Cup is about
collective memories and and shared
memories and unified memories and the
World Cup is a rare thing a unites fans
of every club team suddenly to get
behind I mean just in the entire country
there's rooting for that team it's an
incredibly powerful emotional force
which actually has given me to be candid
some of my most powerful memories in my
life at all it's sad to say and I hope
my wife's not listening like so many of
my most powerful memories are World Cup
to world curve and so for England to
have another set of memories
anticipation running into a possible
final answer which I can't even believe
to be candid I can't conceive of England
winning to the edge economy in my
imagination it's like trying to imagine
that space is infinite trying to imagine
infinite space infinite numbers an
England that wins is in that category
I cannot imagine those feelings idle I
want more of those feelings I don't
expect victory that they would expect
glory
don't expect trophies and should like
this feeling these emotions this
sensitive the anticipation is the
greatest thing isn't it at the end of
the day yeah it's all Winnie the Pooh
quote that that the feeling of I'm
paraphrasing but eating honey is
wonderful but the anticipation of being
about to eat honey is even better and I
want more and want more of an
anticipation than if you understand
there's no way they're gonna win there's
no way either of these teams are going
to be France but it's it's the emotional
journey the roller coaster the hopes the
dreams the glory the shared bonding
among sports fans ultimately it's the
only point of life enjoy the pain Roger
whether it happens today or it happens
over the weekend okay
Oh Dan Patrick and all you guys thank
you for your support of the sport it's
been the greatest World Cup ever two
more to glory hopefully to American
glory and to mega Markel's
English accent Thank You Roger that's a
Roger berry men and blazers for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]